en guinée les putschistes ont désigné
leur nouveau chef le capitaine moussa
dadis camara s'est présenté hier soir
comme le nouveau président de la
république quelques heures auparavant il
avait été acclamé par la foule dans les
rues de la capitale conakry la junte
militaire promet d'organiser des
élections libres
fin décembre 2010 luc la gamme ou chez
hier chef des putschistes
le voilà aujourd'hui chef de l'état le
capitaine moussa dadis camara ancien
chef de la section carburant au service
des armées a donc pris du grade et cela
méritait bien une parade dans les rues
de conakry
les putschistes défilent dans la
capitale pour afficher à toute la
population la détermination de la junte
et de leur nouveau président
autoproclamé
[Applaudissements]
nous la leur on est content on est
satisfait on a nommé officier si nous
savons a pas de zone euro a pas d effet
apparaît difficile pour la population de
ne pas à clamer ce nouvel homme fort qui
donne 24 heures aux membres du
gouvernement et aux militaires n'ont
rallié pour se rendre dans un camp de la
capitale à défaut les putschistes
procéderont un ratissage en règle du
pays ils n'ont pas l'idée que le peuple
ni honnête et la d84 la tête et là le
wydad et lorient qui sait mais le
président à peine mort les voilà en
nouveaux maîtres de ce pays l'un des
plus pauvres de la planète
la junte s'engage à organiser des
élections libres et transparentes fin
2010 une promesse de démocratie que
lansana conté l'ancien président avait
fait en son temps en 1984 à la faveur
d'un coup d'état qui l'avait porté au
pouvoir